at the close of the age of fire all
lands meet at the end of the earth great
Kingdom and anaemic townships will be
one the same and I tide of human
enterprise all for naught that's why I'm
so taken by this grand design this must
be what it's like to be a god
welcome everyone to the Ring City so I
can show you ten minutes of this first
level and then I can show you about five
minutes of the boss I got this equip
these great sword from the hag just
before and it's really good
[Music]
don't judge me she told me died it was
embarrassing she had to go but as she
got it she said something about hoping
to see an angel and it looks like she
just missed it then actually I'm pretty
sure it's her death that caused this
angel to spawn because I've never seen
it here before her death but we'll talk
about the Angels more later the first
weapon we have in our sights is the
aquamarine dagger which is just beyond
this corralled Legion night.the her old
legion according to their gear once came
here seeking the Dark Soul however they
eventually sank into the dark their
weapons corroding and their bodies
bloating and we don't know yet maybe
they did find the Dark Soul in some
capacity for their head appears to be
this swirling mass of humanity which if
you jump attack it it can save you and
difficult to fight above is the
lightsaber
I mean aquamarine dagger and it has a
weapon art that's like Frida's scythe
where it extends the blade and your move
set at the cost of some movement speed
and focus the dagger reads it is fitted
with aquamarine crystals and engraved
with a prayer in the old tongue toward
off incidents perhaps it is a parting
gift given to one sent out on great
travel it's quite effective against
these murk men and the murk men are like
human corpses that are corroded by the
dark some as you'll see here are
possessed by soldier eggs which and I
quote have a grave likeness to the human
form
apparently you can destroy these soul
drugs as they fly towards you look at
this I only figured this out because I
rolled with the thorns armor on which
does damage when you roll and that
probably would have been really useful
information in this scenario but back to
the dagger I think this will be a top
tier weapon in terms of fashion and in
terms of damage it's pretty great
against humanoid enemies because it can
stun lock them but as you'll see during
the boss fight later activating the
weten art can be a bit of a liability
next the angel if you have a keen eye
then you would have noticed this pillar
of light in the distance it illuminates
at the same time the angel appeared so I
ran down there to check it out and
this pillar breaks through a cathedral
wall and reveals the path to lap the
amnesiac hollow oh look at you you've
got your head screwed on correct and
traffic to meet a kindred spirit on this
godforsaken crag pull me lad I can't
remember my real name so let's just go
with that I have a feeling you just said
we'd make a fabulous team where's the
teamwork I feel like it's not in this
guy's character to help me let's try
again see oh you'll see you'll see
as you know honestly there's something I
should tell you I'm a whole oh yeah I
try to play it off but I haven't a clue
about my past who I was or what I live
for
not even my own blistered name that'll I
have come here searching for the purging
Monument said to be in the ring city
where the pygmies have found the dark
soul at the dawn of fire reside all I
can say is those little stones aren't
doing much to help me remember anymore
the little stones he's talking about
obviously purging stones which are
commonly used in lond or to cure
hollowing and to stave off the undead
curse and for someone who is as immortal
as lap whose identity we were pretty
sure of in the last video if you want to
spoil it apparently for him even these
stones stop being effective after a
while back down below lap is our
original target which was this thing
which I've started calling the Lundell
grower it's this fleshy parasite that
appears to be attached over the shell of
a dead pilgrim and I always assumed that
the shells were like those shells that
you saw on the blue robed clerics which
state that the shells keep out the pus
of man which is that black muck that had
infested the rest of Warrick so the fact
that this avatar this parasite appears
over the shell of the pilgrim leads me
to believe that whatever this creature
is it's what the pilgrim wanted to
become after all it's kind of like a
caterpillar becoming a butterfly
after the cocoon phase and after all the
pilgrims of wand or
we learn from y'all were destined to die
and craved death so perhaps this rebirth
into an angel is their goal and I guess
for hollows it is a more powerful form
and this certainly is a step forward at
least in terms of evolution but what is
their goal now that's what we've yet to
discover a bunch more pilgrims
can be found in this arena where you
fight one more heralds night and beyond
this a drop down into the next zone that
I'm not allowed to show you but I am
allowed to show you this
a banal and a deep dark hole carved out
of a tree from time to time voices bring
from the depth of the cavity even now
matter wings of the merry demon that
Prince lorian's al-kahf I'm sure animal
terms of an afflicted thing yet
cursing men the demon Prince this fight
has changed we're in a previous patch
you were only possessed by one demon at
the start now there are two of the stuff
though I'd argue that they do a bit less
damage now from what I remember the boss
really shouldn't be called the demon
from below it should be called camera
because that's what you're really
fighting and though it's not a bad fight
it's quite good it just gets a little
too chaotic at times in my opinion so
the main mechanic when there's two of
them is this when a demon is red that
means it's powered up and it means that
it will tend towards using fire imbued
melee attacks eventually though it will
lose that flame with a slam attack and
then will resort to poison toxic and
corrosion until it powers up again and
this poison form is where most of your
damage should come in and it's also
where the demon Prince will come out the
demon Prince after his defeat to Lorien
retreated to beneath the earth and lost
the memory of the flame that burned
within him marking the end of demon kind
the weapons from his soul of the last
flames kindled by the prince and with
the death of the old demon king in the
overworld surely these mark the end of
chaos and it seemed
one fact remains the same here though
depending on which one you kill first
the move set of the demon prints will
change so if you kill the one on the
right the demon in pain first you'll
face a version of the demon prints with
laser attacks and this version is far
easier in my opinion because these at ya
don't get hit and if you kill the one on
the left first the demon from below then
it will lead to a demon prince fight
with true chaos flame attacks he summons
these orbs that bombard you from a
distance and this meteor storm that I
could never effectively dodge it killed
me so hard that it [ __ ] broke my
editing software
ultimately though this boss is undone by
a high stability high fire resistant
shield
you don't even need to dodge really just
use the Black Knight shield so the last
thing I want to leave you on is this I
think it's a good statement to go into
the DLC with from a law point of view
anyway so the Herald's Knights came down
here seeking the Dark Soul and they
failed a wonderer apparently on great
travels was given the aquamarine dagger
and left it behind and I think that
maybe Prince lothric monk has been here
- since he defeated the demon Prince
before it I rode deep beneath the ground
noting its wounds and of course Gail is
summonable for this fight and we know
why it is down here all of these people
likely what here looking for the Dark
Soul and the question becomes why were
they seeking the Dark Soul what powers
does it have and can it really create a
new world as Gail and Arya hopeful one
more week and we'll know thank you for
watching also if you want to learn
everything we currently know about the
Rings city I'll be it without footage to
back it up you can watch this video and
I believe there's a new trailer dropping
soon so check that out thank you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]